COLEMAN FORMER TAMPA BAY
LIGHTNING.
SO I'MO BACKLUND.
HE'LL WORK IT UP THE BOARDS
AND TAKE A LOOK ONMcDONAGH THERP
AND CLEAR FOR TAMPA BAY. PUCK.
AND NOW NOAH SERGACHEV.
JOSEPH HEADS BACK THE OTHER
WAY.
IN COMES THE GOES WIDE.
DID A GOOD JOB TO SETTLE
THAT DOWN.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN TIPPED BY RIP T.
HERE'S A REBOUND.
WATCH JOHOOR
CLEARING ATTEMPT BY TAMPA.
>> Rick: FIFTH LEADING
SCORER IN THE NHL GETETly: REAL.
MUCH BETTER THAN MONDAY ANDWhis]
HE'LL CARRY IN BUTD IT INTO THE.
>> Kelly: SURE D.OFF
SOMEONE'S FOOT ANYW LOOK AT A
COUPLE GOOD SCORING CHANCES.
[ ♪ ]
[ Crowd din ]
>> Kelly: WE HERE
IT GO.
PLAYS HANDLE.
>> Kelly: FANTASTIC SAVE.FF RIGE
WORKING IT IN.
MEANTIME ON THE PLANS
ALLOY YOUR EMPLOYEES T
FRONT TO
GUDBRANSON TURNED ASIDE.
McDONAGH BOBBLED THE PUCK
AND A FABULOUS GAME TO
WATCH.
>> Rick: SHOTS 22-20
JOSEPH DOES.
GOING TO GET THE PUCK TO
COLTON. VASILEVSKIY.
>> Rick: GOOD JOE BIDEN BY
GAUDREAU TO KEEP THE PLAY ON
SIDE.
JOHNNY GAUDREAU WORKING
TOGETHER.
NICE SAVE INSIDE 20 SECONDS
TO GO IN THE PUCK'S GOING TO COE
AROUND FOR THE FAR SIDE.
HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
OUTSTANDING AS
MAROON.NG A CHANCE LATE,
TKACHUK FLIPS THE PUCK IN.
HEADS OFF.T.
HANIFIN.
TKACHUK QUICKLY.
JOHNNY SORT OF FINDS